and by the way at some point i i'd love  to to talk with you about about all this  ufo stuff which which interests me  not not in in in a public fashion but  just  you know um  because i i'm not i don't have any  opinions worth  saying about them  but i it it really i i think it's such  an interesting um topic and um  and such an important topic i mean it's  it seems to me remarkable that it's not  on everybody's tongue you know  why why why aren't we all talking about  this you know why aren't we it's like  incredible but  for whatever reason when i started  interviewing ufo people i initially was  doing it because  i'm interested is is there something to  this whether  obvious these crap if they are physical  seem to break the laws of physics the  conservation of momentum if they have  any mass conservation of momentum and if  they're indeed physical  or just  or just or just false reports